mi chiamo jane tu sei io jane tu ed io
tu proprio io
già in un blocco ginocchio
jane brock james entrati to tarzan e
jane to tarda di io ok ciao a tutti i
ragazzi e canzoni della disney adesso
non so poi meglio sempre amati sin da
quando ero piccolo si ok però sono
pornografici ma te lo vedi che sono
pornografici sono bellissimi giochi non
te ne accorgi
certamente no te l'ho detto se son pieni
di messaggi subliminali si messaggi
subliminali che stanno ovunque come le
piattole i pidocchi maria de filippi
belen rodriguez nella segreti copertino
in una delle torri del castello maestoso
una forma un tantino strano oppure
quando il matrimonio di ieri che quella
[ __ ] sta venendo celebrato il prete
sembra particolarmente contento per non
parlare di bianca perni che mentre
stanno in picchiata su quella specie di
gallina volante passano davanti alla
finestra porosa poi ci si ma che si
sente solo sulla rupe che lancia e
polline per aree con strane scritte
aladin dove per due volte all'interno
del cartone poi sentire una voce che
bisbiglia teichmann soft e tu sai cosa
vuol dire questa cosa vuol dire
sbagliati insomma è una cosa importante
è malata sì è vero però lasciatemi dire
una cosa io da piccolo a malapena capivo
le canzoni che cantavano
fantasie star male quando mormoni ciao o
loro l'angolo figuriamoci andare a
cogliere i messaggi subliminali voglio
dire molto probabilmente non avrei
capito allusione noti che hanno se
cartoni della disney fossero stati così
è che questi sono i gioielli di mio
padre
rubati senza il suo permesso ma questo
lo sta facendo solamente perché vuoi
avere delle gambe delle gambe per
ballare per saltare e prendere a spasso
per la wme come si dice o se strada e
non solo
e da stamattina che ci provo niente una
lampada magica che non vuole funzionare
senti adesso fermi ci pensino a
scaricare quando non è una lampada
tranquillo che in questo modo ciascun
genio beh tu crei dicono le cose che
appartengono ma gli anni verso la
mission ieri andatevene dove la tua
gente della mia terra ei sei commosso
prima non del tutto nulla non avrei
capito nulla piuttosto voi avete qualche
esempio da parte di messaggio
subliminale e soprattutto quali sono i
nostri tre cartoni della disney
preferiti
scrivete un commentino lasciate un vita
è disposta a scusate un'ultima domanda
che mi è venuta adesso ma anche voi non
capitato una mazza di quello che dicevo
nelle canzoni o isolamenti che non ne
conosciamo